unlike some other Traditions that we
have discussed the stoa was actually a
literal School in the sense of a
connected group of people with a leader
and cryus was one such significant head
of this school he said to have written
an insane amount of works over 700 books
in which he presented his
interpretations of Zeno's ideas and the
basics of stoicism it gives me no
pleasure to tell you that not a single
of these Works have survived we do know
of chrispus ideas and significance
though through references and in other
works and can thus get an idea of his
thought he made significant Innovations
in all kinds of philosophical Fields
perhaps above all in logic and we will
have time to get into some of these
ideas soon